شنو اكثر شيء قراتيه عبر تويتر مرعب
والله الحقيقه كلها هي تغريدات اللي بتحكي
عن الذكاء الاصطناعي
رح ياخذنا وقت على بيننا يقضوا علينا
نهائيا هذا بالفعل هو خبرنا في تغريده
مرعبه لسؤال جوهري هذه الايام كم سنه
لدينا قبل ان يقتلنا الذكاء الاصطناعي
جميعا بالفعل هذا ما طرحه مالك تويتر
كالعاده والملياردير
الامريكي للجدل دوما ايلون ماسك والمحذر
دائما من مخاطر ومن ضروره ايضا او يتحدث
دائما عن ضروره وضع معايير لضبطه مغرد
يدعى ماركاندرسن عرف عن نفسه بانه شريك في
شركه تعمل على تطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي
اجاب بكل دقه انه امامنا
69.420 سنه قبل الفناء طيب كان قد طمئن
سابقا لان الذكاء الاصطناعي لن يدمر
العالم بل وقد ينقده في الواقع خيرونا
حيرونا يدمرنا ولا مش رح يدمرنا ان شاء
الله خير لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات